okay let's go
touring test and love enterprise i have
this intuition call me crazy
but we that a machine to pass the
touring test and is full
whatever the spirit of it is we can talk
about how to formulate
the perfect touring test that that
machine has to
be conscious or we at least have to uh
i have a very low bar of what
consciousness is a dentist
i tend to think that the emulation of
consciousness is as good as
consciousness
so like consciousness is just a dance a
social
a social uh shortcut like a nice useful
tool
but i tend to connect intelligence
consciousness together so by
by that do you uh maybe just
to ask what uh what role does
consciousness play do you think in
passing the touring test well look i
mean it's almost
tautologically true that if we had a
machine that passed the turing test then
it would be emulating consciousness
right so if your position is that you
know emulation of consciousness is
consciousness
then certain you know by by definition
any machine that passed the touring test
would be
conscious but it's uh uh but i mean we
know that you could say that you know
that that is just a way to rephrase the
original question you know is an
emulation of consciousness
you know necessarily conscious right and
you can you know
i hear i'm not saying anything new that
hasn't been debated
ad nauseum in the literature okay but
you know you could uh
imagine some very hard cases like
imagine a machine
that passed the touring test but it did
so just by an enormous
cosmological sized look-up table that
just cached
every possible conversation that could
be had the old chinese room
well well yeah yeah but but this is uh
uh
i mean i mean the chinese room actually
would be doing some computation
at least in searle's version right here
i'm just talking about a table lookup
okay now it's true that for
conversations of a reasonable length
this
you know lookup table would be so
enormous that wouldn't even fit in the
observable universe okay but supposing
that you could build a big enough lookup
table
and then just you know uh uh pass the
touring test just by looking up what the
person said
right are you going to regard that as
conscious okay
let me try to make this yeah yeah formal
and then you can shut it down
i think that the emulation of something
is that something if there exists in
that system a black box that's full of
mystery
so like uh full of mystery to whom
to uh human in inspectors so does that
mean that consciousness is relative to
the observer
like could something be conscious for us
but not conscious for an alien that
understood better what was happening
inside the black box yes so that if
inside the black box is just a look up
table
the alien that saw that would say this
is not conscious to us
another way to phrase the black box is
layers of abstraction
which make it very difficult to see to
the actual underlying functionality of
the system
and then we observe just the abstraction
and so it looks like magic to us
but once we understand the inner
machinery it stops being
magic and so like that's a prerequisite
is that you can't know how it works some
part of it
because then there has to be in our
human mind uh
entry point for the magic so that
that's that's a formal definition of the
system yeah well look i mean i
i explored a view in this essay i wrote
called the ghost and the quantum turing
machine uh seven years ago
that is uh related to that except that i
did not wanna
have consciousness be relative to the
observer right because i think that
you know if consciousness means anything
it is something that is experienced by
the entity that is conscious
right you know like i don't need you to
tell me that i'm conscious
right nor do you need me to to to
to tell you that you are right so uh
so but but basically what i explored
there is you know are there
uh aspects of a of a system like uh like
a brain
that uh that just could not be predicted
even with arbitrarily advanced future
technologies
just because of chaos combined with
quantum mechanical uncertainty
you know and things like that i mean
that that actually could be
a a property of the brain you know if
true
that would distinguish it in a
principled way at least from any
currently existing computer
not from any possible computer but from
yeah yeah let's do a thought experiment
so
yeah if i gave you information
that you're in the entire history of
your life
basically explain away free will with a
look-up table say that
this was all predetermined that
everything you experienced has already
been predetermined
wouldn't that take away your
consciousness wouldn't you yourself that
wouldn't
experience of the world change for you
in a way that's
you you can't well let me put it this
way if you could do
like in a greek tragedy where you know
you would just write down a prediction
for what i'm going to do
and then maybe you put the prediction in
a sealed box
and maybe you know you you uh open it
later and you
show that you knew everything i was
going to do or you know
of course the even creepier version
would be you tell me the prediction
and then i try to falsify it and my very
effort to falsify it makes it come true
right but let's let's you know let's
even forget that you know that version
is as convenient as it is for fiction
writers right
let's just let's just do the version
where you put the prediction into a
sealed envelope okay
but uh if you could reliably predict
everything that i was going to do
i'm not sure that that would destroy my
sense of being conscious
but i think it really would destroy my
sense of having free will
you know and much much more than any
philosophical conversation could
possibly do that
right and so i think it becomes
extremely interesting to ask
you know could such predictions be done
you know even in principle
is it consistent with the laws of
physics to make such predictions
to get enough data about someone that
you could actually generate such
predictions without having to kill them
in the process to you know
slice their brain up into little slivers
or something i mean
theoretically possible right well um i
don't know i mean i mean it might be
possible but only at the cost of
destroying the person
right i mean it depends on how low you
have to go
in sort of the substrate like if there
was a nice
digital abstraction layer if you could
think of each neuron
as a kind of transistor computing a
digital function
then you could imagine some nano robots
that would go in
and we just scan the state of each
transistor you know of each neuron
and then you know make a a good enough
copy
right but if it was actually important
to get down to the molecular or the
atomic level
then you know eventually you would be up
against quantum effects you would be up
against the unclonability of quantum
states
so i think it's a question of uh how
good of a replica
how good does the replica have to be
before you're going to count it as
actually a copy of you
or as being able to predict your actions
uh that's a totally open question
yeah yeah yeah and and especially once
we say
that well look maybe there's no way to
pre you know to make a deterministic
prediction
because you know there's all you know we
know that there's noise buffeting the
brain around
presumably even quantum mechanical
uncertainty
you know affecting the sodium ion
channels for example whether they open
or they close
um you know there's no reason why
over a certain time scale that shouldn't
be amplified just like we imagine
happens with the weather
or with any other you know chaotic
system uh
so um so if if if that stuff
is is important right then uh
then then you know we would say uh well
you know you you you can't
uh uh you know you're you're never gonna
be able to make an
accurate enough copy but now the hard
part is well what if someone can make a
copy
that sort of no one else can tell apart
from you right
it says the same kinds of things that
you would have said
maybe not exactly the same things
because we agree that there's noise
but it says the same kinds of things and
maybe you alone would say no
i know that that's not me you know it's
it doesn't share my
i haven't felt my consciousness leap
over to that other thing
i still feel it localized in this
version right
then why should anyone else believe you
you